baked cheese house is famous for
attending holiday in winter markets
all over the country their signature
dish is reclat
a traditional swiss cheese heated over
an open flame and melted onto sandwiches
i'm also trying a chimney cake filled
with hot chocolate and a mozzarella
cheesesteak to see which food will come
out on top
[Music]
so today we're at the bank of america
winter village in bryant park one of the
holiday highlights of manhattan
it's filled with lots of holiday fun
from ice skating to gift shopping
and of course delicious streets the
winter village at bryant park is
inspired by european holiday markets
and its shops highlight the foods and
cultures of over 25
different countries people come to the
winter village to get a taste of europe
trying everything from hot spanish
churros to seeing one of a kind
handcrafted turkish lamps it is one of
the most popular winter
events in new york city attracting over
3 million visitors
every year we have a 17 000 square foot
skating rink that is the only free
admission skating rink in new york city
we have a 55-foot norway spruce
christmas tree with 3 000 christmas
ornaments
we really have everything here all in
one place and we're right in the center
of midtown manhattan
bricklette cheese is extremely popular
at winter markets all across europe
and has been a staple of swiss and
french cuisines for centuries
in fact back in the 13th century swiss
shepherds would heat wheels of this
alpine cheese over an open flame
and scrape it on pickles potatoes and
bread
soon after the cheese was named raclette
based off of the french word
clay which means to scrape the founder
of baked cheese house fell in love with
raclette cheese at the european holiday
markets and decided to bring it to
holiday markets
all over america each day here they sell
over 500
sandwiches which comes to a grand total
of 15
wheels of raclette used per day her
brother posted this on his instagram
story a week ago
and i was like i need to find this
cheese i'm familiar with reclaim
and i love it we lived in switzerland
where you really got
great yeah i mean why not right
delicious really good excellent it
tastes like heaven
i love it because it's like a show while
you wait and then you just start
drooling all over yourself here it is
i can smell this raclette over the three
blocks
of the park the cheese smells that
strong but in a good way
classic french baguette you know it's
crispy it's just has a nice give to it
you have the salty prosciutto she added
some scallions and then
also some dijon mustard so that kind of
brightens it up a little bit
but the star of the show is the creamy
dreamy raclette
it is buttery and it just is so
comforting
i feel like i'm at a ski lodge in
switzerland
we're traveling from switzerland to
hungary to try their traditional dessert
the chimney cake similar to ricklette
the chimney cake has a long history in
hungary
and can be dated all the way back to
1450.
medieval texts spoke of wrapping a strip
of dough around a baking spit
and spinning the cake over a flame the
recipe for chimney cakes changed over
the years from
flattening dough to sprinkling sugar on
top until it evolved into what it is
today
the owner of the stackery was inspired
by the chimney cakes on a trip to
hungary and decided to bring it back to
america
they came up with their own twist making
the chimney cake a cup for delicious hot
chocolate topped with
mini marshmallows they wrapped their
homemade dough on custom
spindles that they order from europe and
they make them fresh every morning
oh my heart just skipped to be oh my god
it's like my wedding day
the hot chocolate is rich it's decadent
hot chocolate this is the really good
stuff
we have this chimney cake which is
essentially a nice
yeast donut with a crispy outside super
soft inside
and then the cinnamon sugar and it goes
so well with the hot chocolate
finally it's time for our wacky snack
our foods have come from all over europe
today but our final contestant is all
american
the hungry man cheesesteak the trufflist
is known in new york for having
everything truffle
they source their truffles from all over
europe and turn them into artisanal
truffle ingredients
making everything from truffle oil to
truffle hot sauce
since 2014 the travelist has also
attended holiday pop-up shops
selling cheesesteaks with truffle every
winter we just wanted to
show people that truffles can be super
approachable just take a classic
american sandwich like the cheese steak
and truffle it up
so that's our part of our identity is to
just be super approachable
their hungry man cheesesteak is their
most daring menu item
filled with truffle oil mozzarella
sticks and topped with curly fries
and more truffle oil
[Music]
with all of this going on it's kind of
hard to have just one thing that stands
out
if you like cheese and you're a
cheesesteak lover
you definitely should try this this has
so much character it's an experience you
really just gotta try
the holiday market
the christmas spirit is alive i
feel amazing because i ate so many great
foods today
but i have to tell you guys my favorite
and that was
there's a drum roll there the
legs the reason i picked the raclette is
because
that alpine cheese that's heated in
front of you
has a dramatic effect and then the taste
is also so dramatic
it's buttery it's soft it's creamy
it's warming and we need that here in
the winter village
all in all it was fantastic well that's
all for this episode of festival foodies
i will see you next time stay hungry